[Music]
does anybody else need a paper copy
okay politics for instance meetings of
the minutes held on 1218 receive
declarations of interest item 6 which
disease poisons hide something
can I please remind members that
technically some of the paperwork is
actually under PMC so we need to go into
that we would need to declare by the sea
the moment
outside piercing I think chairman the
asset delivery program represents a huge
opportunity for this authority to
realize the objectives of the asset
strategy agreed recently by this
committee I'm pleased as portfolio for
enterprise to have this opportunity to
update members on progress of this gold
project this project sees members and
officers continue to work closely
together in order to share and test
ideas to continue to develop the
business case that will see the assets
tragedy brought into reality the asset
strategy has a clear vision to bring
forward an OP NIH's as they face that is
fit for purpose deliver capital receipts
to help fund future investment and
revenue statements as our extremes
enable quality service delivery for
residents and visitors through a
sustained program for transformation the
purpose of this report is twofold
or sorry threefold to improve the
aesthetic outline case to improve the
outcomes of the member working party and
that the officers continue to prepare
the outline business case in
consultation with the member working
party members the satiric outline case
presented to the House September set out
the various development delivery and
disposal options for the council's key
succeed lis assets to achieve the
objectives as laid out in the asset
strategy
the static l1 case is a project
management tool so if you control
conformed proof of concept for the
program officers have held series of
detailed site visits workshops Pacific
suspicion the Pacific workshops we're
also held with councils technical
advisors gleets the workshops revisited
the principles of the agreed assets
tragedy complained at a quantitative
scoring exercise for the potential
options for each key strategic site and
consider the potential operational
required for each site within the sock
in accordance with industry practice a
range of options for each sites was
considered these were evaluated against
a set of key criteria with clear link
and linkage linkage to the asset
strategy the working party has reviewed
challenged and endorsed the quantitive
scoring options appraisal which is in
pendeks - which will be 4 which will
form the basis of the OBC the work the
working poet has indicated to officers
that the sock does prove that this is a
viable project and should progress to
OBC stage finally the report proposes
that the officers continue to consult
with the member work party in
preparation of the OBC in closing this
has been an excellent example of
officers and members working together on
a complex critical project in order to
bring forward clearer proposals to
deliver the council's objectives I would
like to invite the member working party
to present the outcomes of their work so
I'll pass it over to Council Dave
spearing
do you wish to add anything to that to
talk Thank You chairman I've just been
told by over said in terms of how
closely officers and members working
together through the working group and I
think the next stage is to present that
work to the members of channel yeah
thank you Jim I think there's one point
we should find you very clear we've got
two sections on this item appendix 1 & 2
I know a penny to two is PNC I don't
know how you want to play this but in
all honesty there's some integrated you
could find yourself now answering
questions because you're concerned so
anything sinister about Park to be
organized I'm certain you're gonna ask
questions down this way well I can't
answer under this section it's gonna
have to be under Section two but we're
going on to see how we go and have to
fight from there it's just a caveat
appendix once again everyone I'm happy
to be able you German Jews just to
clarify as counsel spoke said that that
the purple paper is and let's see how we
go straight to okay you've heard the
statement from from counter IO no let's
try and get down to some of the more
basic things that the workings would be
our first question is who is bleed
never heard of them simple as that
we then ask them you know who you work
for what's your background all this
other stuff
as you can see this is all down in the
papers that you should have written
we've subsequently met a couple of their
representatives who I think all the
working committee feel confident
professional on these guys nothing like
we've come across in some of the other
operations that we've been been working
at wait
these guys have good travels they asked
us what I consider appropriate questions
they have appropriate answers they have
recommendations and devices can we just
make the point this is not set in stone
anything we've got here I very much hope
that you will ask us questions because
it is critically important we get this
right I've got one opportunity to
realize as much as we can from the
assets we have available we're not just
looking to sell everything on and take
the money on run we're looking in areas
to have council house perhaps in in
rival in Riley and in Radford we're
looking to where possible to have a
long-term revenue stream to the council
for years to come so you know this was
is a more basic coming about the other
issues the simple fact is that we've got
at least three assets Freight house
where we're running at losses of 80,000
pounds a year we've got Mill Hall where
it's 119 but the Civic suite at 90
thousand a year so to do nothing is not
an option it's as simple as that
now we're talking about how do we
progress things in more audibly do them
and we've got to make sure that we get
it right this is not just a question of
building a nice little office further
right for district council this is about
realizing the best we can for the
residents of this district going on
along those lines I think that we pretty
much would have come up with the same
conclusions that bleeds did if we'd have
done a scoring system and though please
work with Mac to cardless it to be
honest the working group would have come
up in virtually the same criteria it's
not rocket science I mean we can work it
out yeah they've come up with an our own
scoring system very start and it does
compare with theories
and in subsequent to that so I'll tell
you what they might go yeah it was it
wasn't anything surprising I think what
we we want to make sure is that we get
this right though any question don't my
house small has got to be asked we won't
get this done there are obvious
situations where there is a no-brainer
the present council office is an object
for purpose they're too big for what the
council actually wants they're not very
work friendly so we need to deal with
that and move on what we do and how we
do it is is discretion of debate we're
not at the stage yet where we have paid
in financial press occasions put to us
that's the next stage but pretty much I
think some of the ideas that the scoring
dictates is not necessarily ideological
ideas let's put the council offices in
in Rochford this part of the district
council is because land prices in Raley
will attract a better value than they
will in ROG fit and that's that's the
logic behind some of the decisions we've
made so I'm pretty comfortable with it
the reports that we've have presented to
us and I'm sure if you know I would
expect you to fire some questions at us
hopefully we will have the answers
hopefully we've already asked them so we
should have the answers and I think that
pretty much sums it up chairman does any
other the working party was 20 I would
just like to say
in this mobile terms of reference the
first paragraph is particularly relevant
and has to ensure that the best uses
major sites and property and the
possibilities depend on location and
income-generating because explore
maximizing both economic and social
values the district I do that
particularly relevant to this might do
everything fun no it's just I think
sorry when a small point remember we met
please and have a lot of talks with them
their confidence in them built out and
we were very happy with dealing with
them did you want them more anything's
been said yes facing very professional
sometime we're talking about there for
traffic or good working develop avenues
put smoke good estate questions not so
much a question needs more thanks to the
working party that for the work that
they've done but just one suggestion one
of the things suggested in this and I
know that some has already been done on
this is about risks mission I think it's
what without ceasing this although there
is some respects is in there as well but
sometimes those risks of change over
time so I think it's something that
might need another look at from time to
time just to make sure they're all up to
date we've got bricks ticked happening
we've got other things happening
property prices are yo-yoing a bit so I
think we really need to make sure we're
we have a risk that we rate the risk in
accordance with the particular property
we're looking at and make sure we know
exactly what the reefs and and also what
the rewards are as well just to make
sure that we know exactly where we are
so the things don't overtake us all we
didn't do something unnecessary
couple things home 6.49 wine the
resource implications preparing SOC
obviously there's been a significant
amount of work is being done here which
obviously must have cost the council
quite there are concerns at the moment
we have no piglet actually the hotel you
and I understand from what he's written
there that he is coming from existing
resources but we should at least have
some sort of foster I'm wondering why
that has been separated out because to
me it sounds as though a way of trying
to prevent bringing the budget soon for
council because we're not exceeding the
fifty thousand pounds in it for the
opposite to expect so I'd be interested
to know exactly what that amount is
that's been spent so far I'm guessing it
must be a significant amount the only
other thing was just out of interest on
the Working Committee this is very much
of a building project how many people on
the working party have actually got
building experience trim so in terms of
the costings for the outline business
case that support in the early report
service committee in September and
that's for travel pounds
that's much fifty thousand pounds I've
supported this committee atomicity
September meeting that's been spent at
this stage that's to do it in its part
the next day that was the OBC and
totally yes not just this section so
she'll click on the commitment can I
understand them why ease that that means
separator this is one project I don't
understand why this has been separated
out because he because over the 50
thousands of my understanding is that we
have to bring the budget for games sorry
I understand what countries are saying
separated out we've got the initial
fifty thousand and the ongoing which
we've got in the item six here listed as
being silica 57 so we're looking at a
the expense on the upfront reports that
we're having on this of being in the
region of 100,000 pounds which actually
brings that into some of the full
council should be year we're talking
about the same philosophy one 157 is
written here so don't have to reveal the
cost of preparing the SOC has been
contained with the existing within
existing resources allocated less extra
your cost associated with the next stage
of the book OBC and workplace try to use
this to make you 50,000 so is that being
Brittany's that been written wrongly to
give the wrong impression HM the 50,000
pounds is the full finger for the
obesity outline business case someone
see what you're seeing this evening
right so this is not an additional
50,000 that we're looking at but the old
overnight so that's misleading in that
paragraph could that be rewritten the
piece geminate members members agree the
intention the intention was not to
mislead I we could maybe make this
slightly clearer I think what we were
saying this as some resources with all
been allocated to asset type work and a
lot of the work that we'd already done
was then through a strategic outline
case so we appreciated some additional
work was required and that was what was
estimated to cost 50,000 pounds on top
of any resources so it will be done for
the initial stages of work so we we
tried to use it and work we'd already
done which didn't incur in the
additional cost and that was brought
into the strategic outline case the
negative further into the outline case
we needed a further understand the
confusion I understand it might be
slightly wedding committees are kind of
that would rectify
within the minutes so that remains with
your second question does anybody else
do you want to mention about to
experience
oh yeah that's a large project I don't
think any of us have had the experience
of be the first to say we have the
experience of doing developments of this
size this is going to be part of where
we go in future who do we work with what
this is all about the partnership this
is the next big this is the crunch bit
where we start working out where we go
who we go there with and you know
obviously we're gonna keep coming back
to yourselves as investment board and
subsequently for council to get your
approval to do this we'll do our
homework please we'll make their
recommendations we'll find out who we're
going to work with the risk the elements
what percentage what we are giving what
the developer is going to give in
hopefully some of these opportunities
but no I don't don't protester to be a
building construction engineer really
just help me tonight like no casual
comfort or just to say chair but I think
that's the whole point working with
leads because we're actually
entertaining their expertise and all the
projects that we can see from these
papers that they've been involved in
basically so we know we yes all right
we're paying for that advice but we're
getting good advice and yes I think
that's that's really helpful to us and I
think it's really giving us direction in
these projects actually not just to say
to chair that I've spent the last 20
years of a key major construction
projects so my experience in delivering
major projects including PFI
or becoming pop I love how this project
thanks Jeremy
a couple of questions I'm hopefully
fairly simple
what's gleets is roll20 and well so the
arrangement Wiggly is to deliver out our
business case we have an option to look
at the next age which should be a fine
of business case with them but I'll come
back to this committee to make that
decision
most of the babysitter's okay again just
don't think big soon 6.57 when you've
actually work with you with your
surprise you know what you're gonna get
I think that's a bit misleading it's
almost implies that we're gonna like the
fun business case after we've done the
procurement so the the procurement
envisaged at the moment is a competitive
dialogue process which would involve the
evolution of their solution so it would
be impossible to write the FPC before
the solution is agreed however because
all in order to keep the competitive
process
Vidur friendly the standard operating
practice is to simply deliver heads of
terms and then to close out those heads
of terms and formal agreements after
close of dialogue when you're down to
plunk bidder so that is the point of
which we would then be able to start
crystallizing the final business case to
make sure that the feed which was
finally submitted by that preferred
bidder was indeed affordable value for
money and metal object is before we
actually close out the deal
okay I think coming up song did
transform this because I've done this
Sevilla they normally between the
distance cases if you're doing the
Treasury modern properly through gateway
review so to be an independent
assessment of the business cases
presented are we don't to do that I'm a
little plant ships get low reviewer and
we can tap into that if you would like
to there is a cost associated with doing
that in my experience there are
opportunities when you can get the best
from that but clearly puts delay or so
into the process I think it's one of
those cost-benefit analyses that we'll
have to undertake at each stage of the
procurement my view is is that
personally if there is an opportunity to
pause between the crystallization of
your OBC and and finally going to
procurement during which period of time
we talking about soft market testing but
that might be an opportune moment to do
that the cost of a local partnerships
get a review somewhere in the region for
ten thousand pounds so these things are
not cheap so we would need to consider
that whether that's appropriate at the
time to determine is that per project
yes per gateway everyone between each
stage there suppose it's I notice seven
thousand pounds yes absolutely just I
think it's cost both announced weights
and we we would we would I could speak
to two colleagues that have many
informal basis about what value could we
could derive and how quickly they can
see liberated required I mean I thought
some experience the gateway with you may
take three days at most it's time to go
away with you is is yes it's three days
on the site on one day three days of
interviewing one day actual delivery
back so yes I think it is capable of
being done the only could be done in my
experience of gateway reviews probably
in excess of thirty of them
you wouldn't tend not to to move away
from the static model because that's the
under license and unpaid 6.58 we've got
the critical success factors left-hand
side we've got the scoring CSS for the
qualitative analysis so the so the only
options for each site where the
qualitative assessment was undertaken
this is the scoring options for each
site that's the story just about that
Chairman that links back there she'll
know back to the advanced strategy that
this makes you agree so it's it's
demonstrating the links that how it can
achieve objectives when the ancestor
Ashley there's a clear link between the
objective the asset and the asset
strategy the application of qualitative
criteria to create a long a long list
process from what you think shortlist as
part of the quantitative analysis which
having there
okay and where we we say they reference
later on and this needs to be nine
assessment it's just an compliance check
to make sure
okay let's go to five six point five
three I can gone there to resolve one
get distribute outline case for the
potential asset to the appendix
can we actually give an approval on that
if we haven't actually gone through the
appendix here
does anybody proper custody pending yes
so we need to move into my second if
anybody's in sync with okay well that
makes this named under Section 104
before we could just interject we've got
three items to resolve directly yeah one
two or three I believe just one is in P
and C is two or three also in fear C can
we take those you can take out can we
can we do do those you guys now before
we go
very interesting 7:3 dependent almost on
one being a pretty yes okay another
section 100 a form of Local Government
Act 1972 the public will be excluded
from the meeting the highlights of the
business on the browser most likely
disclosure of exempt information defined
in paragraph 3 part 1 of the scriptural
12a so much in return the recording and
just to remind members that it is now
being recorded again ok
right I sweep this out and I take one by
one it is proposed that the board
resolves that the strategic outline case
for potential asset delivery program and
he's exempt appendix one be noted reach
emigrated to that the outcome of the
members working party workshops at the
pendings to be approved very a generator
item three that the officers continue to
prepare the outline business case in
consultation with the member working
right okay thank you very much for that
yeah I'd like to just add my thanks to
the working party it has quite well work
and they're working extremely hard on
that and
put a lot of time you notice thank you
at which point I will close the meeting
right just very quickly there is
somebody